let's next go to nico from santa monica
nico you're on the air hi david
how are you i'm good thank you
um so i assume you follow either the new
york or the
new york times or bloomberg vaccine
tracker correct yes i do
i was wondering so that the johnson
johnson vaccine has been approved
um for use and
that data's not showing up yet are
people just not getting the vaccine
or so as of earlier this week the new so
after the jnj was approved but before
this week when you looked at i haven't
looked at the bloomberg tracker for a
while but when you would look at the new
york times it would say
jnj has been approved we have no data on
it
it's not included in our tracker as of
this week there's a new message on the
new york times tracker which says
jnj one dose is now included here and we
are including now because it's one dose
if you got the jnj vaccine you're being
counted by the new york times both as
having
full vaccination and as having at least
one dose they're basically double
it's not really double counting you're
just you're part of both categories so
my understanding is now
jnj is in the new york times tracker
okay so so that vaccine data is updated
then yes as far as i know
all right well thank you all right nico
from santa monica with a very
um specific question i guess is what we
would say
why don't we go next to amugo
from florida a mugo you are on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can all
right how are you doing
i'm doing well uh so i kind of have a
few questions
i'm going to start off with this one
right did you hear about the the
nevada democratic party how basically
the establishment just quit
after the socialists won juan raising
all the seats
i saw a headline about it i don't know
the details about what's been going on
in in the nevada democratic party but i
did see the headline yeah
yeah i just thought it was interesting
you know the the socialist president
took over
and you know the the establishment talks
about unity and blah blah blah and then
as soon as you know the people that they
weren't really expecting to win one
they kind of just quit and it was just
one of those like hypocritical type
things like you want to work together
but when you don't get your way you just
just go away that's i didn't like i just
it was just funny to me
yeah it is it is funny based on the
headlines i've seen i plan to do a
deeper dive
on it this weekend when i have some time
to read more stuff about it but i'm
curious as to like the the background on
it i don't know whether this is
something that's been building within
the
democratic party there for some time or
or if this like punctually exploded or
what happened but it's
it sounds very odd and counterproductive
to be quite frank
yeah true and then i guess my second
question was
um on this stimulus package you know you
i feel like what democrats could do
in the 2022 midterms emphasized hey you
know we're trying to pass this bill
and the majority of the gop like
republican voters are on our side
yes but yet no republicans supported it
so couldn't they use that as like a
messaging
tool for 2022 i hope so i've been
talking about this
for a while which is if every republican
wants to vote against something that
many republican voters
actually want there you would hope
that there are political ramifications
to that and
you would imagine that democrats would
figure out a way to try to
hold them to account for that in 2022 by
running on
they voted no on you getting any money
unfortunately political memories are
very short and if we're significantly
recovered by 2022 and republicans have
fully switched over to
the debt the deficit cancel culture all
this stuff
it may just be too late people may have
forgotten about it sadly i hate that
that's a reality
yeah i was thinking about it because
there's a new poll that just came
out um a yougov poll i believe it's
really 75
of americans want this bill and 59 of
republicans want it
but no republicans voted for it so yeah
they're not representing their
constituents by by definition
literally they're in a mathematical
sense they are not doing it
and for all the flaws democrats have i
mean at least they're
trying to get past because there's a lot
of flaws with the bill you know the 15
minimum wage more means testing so
there's a lot of
things that aren't good about it but at
least they're trying to get relief done
but the right's talking about dr seuss
so i don't know this was my exact
commentary which is there's a bunch of
issues where democrats and republicans
aren't very different
but you look at this every republican
voted for people to get
nothing democrats frustratingly
they don't want the 15 minimum wage and
remember it's not like there's there's
democratic senators who would have voted
no even if you push it into the bill
that's the that's the frustration they
added they restricted who gets it but
but they pass something if it were up to
republicans people would get
zero yeah and then like final point is
um
tom cotton i think um i don't know if
you mentioned it i don't know who it was
but tom cotton went on fox news and said
oh
the democrats want to give prisoners
like i can't remember who the church guy
was i can't remember but they want to
give him a 14
check i was the young turks and um
that same provision was in the trump
stimulus bill but now
tom cotton hates enough right democrats
trying to do the exact same thing
wasn't it like the boston bomber they
were talking about yeah the boston bomb
i mean this is the same thing as when
they say there's a projection of a
hundred thousand children coming across
the border
that well those are almost identical
numbers to what there was under trump
it's just fox news wasn't talking about
it then
yeah it's honestly frustrating just like
listening to them it's like listen
democrats have the flaws but at least
they're trying to help you guys just
complain and complain did you see um tim
ryan on the house floor basically
yelling at republicans like i did we're
trying to help the workers like what do
you guys do
you complain and complain so tim ryan's
a good guy we've had him on the show and
i've met him a couple times
really really good guys not my favorite
but at that moment i was like i feel you
man
no no it's not like you know he's he's
not exp inspiring as a progressive
leader but he's
he's relatively progressive and uh a
good a good guy
all right amugo thank you for the call
no problem have a good day
all right there is a mugo from florida
or
florida i should have asked which of the
two he's from actually
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman